english spelling is really hard to learn
because history the examples that are
usually used to demonstrate that are
things like the o-u-g-h words cough
through
dough and so on but there are other
reasons too and one of them involves
this it's a character so important to
english that it has its own name
schwa to explain it let's start by
talking about this letter
what does that sound like in school
we'll talk the name of it a
and sure it can sound like that in words
like later
but you're actually making two separate
vowel sounds there
a sometimes kids are taught this letter
as just
ah and it can sound like that too in
words like cash
but it can also be the or in call and
depending on your accent and i've got a
sound
really posh to make this work it could
also be the r
in bath that's really at the back of the
mouth it sounds completely unnatural for
me
uh but this letter can also sound like
the
uh in about and that sound ah
is the one we're interested in here
linguists have a chart part of the
international phonetic alphabet
to talk about vowel sounds and it goes
all the way from a vowel like
ee which is produced with the highest
bit of your tongue near the front of
your mouth
tongue really close to the roof to
ah highest bit of the tongue at the back
not close to the roof
if you study linguistics uh then your
first few lessons of phonetics
are basically just a group of people all
making the same weird sounds
and then trying to understand what the
bits their mouth are actually doing
uh someone usually tries to poke around
to feel where the tongue is
and uh then nearly makes themselves
throw up anyway
um sitting right in the middle of that
chart
is that uh from about represented by
the schwa it is central everything just
kind of sitting in the middle it's the
vowel that requires the least effort
uh is the vowel you use when you've got
to make a sound but you don't know what
to say
ah so yes schwa is the a
in a bout but it's also the e in
partition the last i
indefinite the first o in potato and the
u in
support i said english spelling was a
mess
no wonder that definite with an a is
such a common misspelling
if you don't know that it has the same
root as finite it's fair to think that
it's spelled that way
that schwa sound definite gives you very
little information about what
letters to use so what's the difference
between those
two words well in finite there's stress
on night
but indefinite we don't stress that
syllable anymore so it gets reduced
meaning that its vowel gets reduced to
schwa the least effort vowel sound
every vowel letter in english a e i o u
is capable of being reduced to schwa not
always
but they're capable of it sometimes
vowels like that are reduced
so much that they disappear entirely in
words like
these your dialect may be different of
course and if you pronounce the words on
their own
there may still be something there but
give me a story to read out about a
separate chocolate camera and there's no
schwa
in the middle of any of those vowels get
reduced even further
in quickly spoken slurred sentences so
the formal way to pronounce this
sentence would be
i'm going to go to the store
but in real life in my accent if i was
just saying that to a friend as i was
headed out the house
i'd reduce it to something like i'm
going to go to the store
almost every vowel in there was schwa
i'm gonna go to the store there was a
bit of stress
on go a bit of effort went in there and
store couldn't get reduced to
stir but other than that it was all
schwa
i'm going to was reduced to amina
american speakers might reduce it
differently to either aimer or
uma that's not lazy that's not wrong
that's just how language works we all
convert between those reduced vowels and
fully spelled out words instinctively
although it's something that people
learning english aren't always taught
they often have to pick that up by
themselves
and that's one of the reasons why
occasionally when you get these
well-meaning spelling reformers
who say well every word should just be
spelled how it sounds
they haven't thought it through there
are loads of english words that have
more than one pronunciation
not just because of accent but because
most of the time
we reduce the vowels to schwa
thanks to my co-authors molly rule and
gretchen mcculloch gretchen has a great
podcast called enthusiasm
the link is in the description
you